Hi, I'm Adil, and what you just watched is an action short film made in Seedance in 4K.
Crazy, right?
So, today we're breaking down how to build shots like these across completely different
settings.
A storm at sea, a desert, a jungle full of monkeys, you learn how to make shots that actually
look cinematic, how to carry a story from the first scene to the twist, and how to do
it without burning credits on random generations.
And you don't need to write anything down.
Everything from this video is in one blog post, the script, the prompts, the asset sheets,
and the Claude scale that writes the Seedance prompts for you.
The link is below.
If you want to master the full process and start making your own viral films, stick with
me until the end.
Alright, before we start, let's watch the full short film.
Behind us, behind us!
Seedance 2.0, Captain Rackham, parrot, desert, jungle